you get this reputation which i'm sure
bedevils you but
uh you're such a nice guy and i i i've
spent a lot of time with you more than
you've wanted uh you are you are a very
nice fellow
but i suspect what are you doing
are you are you new to show business
no i'm just about to storm off your show
in a hub
part of the half hour thing you got to
mic yourself yeah exactly
we're cutting corners around here yeah
yeah uh you know what i'm just curious i
was bringing up
do you ever lose it do you ever get
angry is there an angry tom hanks
uh that my saying is i don't like people
taking advantage of my good nature
uh and when that hap there's a code
there's a code word in the family that
when i use these
these words let me get this straight
that means i've gone off yeah that's
i've gone off the deep end that's sort
of like is that like dad talk let me get
this straight
well it's also for like uh um let let me
get let me get this straight
you were supposed to hold this table and
we're 10 minutes late and so you gave it
away
right let me get this straight i i i i
try to use it in places like
it was a chuck e cheese and we had 14
three-year-olds
it was a big birthday party and they
gave away our table
yeah just because that person's name was
aloysius as well
you know they had the names of the
aloe's birthday there were two aloises
there
who knew you got screwed yeah yeah but
that when when i when i get mad i pull
out the let
let me get this straight like if i have
to like um
let somebody go like uh
i will i will use the let's get this
straight
that rug was given to me by the dalai
lama
and you sent it in for cleaning you're
off the picture i do that kind of stuff
what are you yeah you sound like a real
dude
i was gonna say these examples are
horrible yeah
you are digging yourself a terrible hole
tom nicest guy in show business
you